quand il a jeté son dévolu sur cette
ancienne abbaye du 12e siècle en 2006
Marc-Olivier ne se doutait pas qu'il
allait devoir cohabiter avec un acteur
américain pourtant tout au fond de sa
propriété cachée sous un cotonester on
retrouve la stèle de Yul Brynner c'est
la queue repose les cendres de
l'ancienne star hollywoodienne décédé en
1985 le début d'une nouvelle passion
pour le propriétaire des lieux
à l'époque je ne savais pas grand chose
soyez le bonheur donc pour moi il
faisait partie de ces grands un de ces
grands acteurs comme on acquiert Douglas
John Wayne Frank Sinatra ce sont des
gens qui ont un charisme extraordinaire
quand on les voit passer on se retourne
donc c'est vraiment des gens importants
et bien c'est un peu la même chose pour
yulbrenner finalement donc j'ai appris à
connaître petit à petit et quand on
connaît quelqu'un évidemment on
s'attache à cette personne donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment mon cas
désormais le maître des lieux est
incollables sur la filmographie de son
locataire et pour lui rendre hommage il
lui a même consacré une grange on y
retrouve les affiches de ces films à
succès ainsi que de nombreux produits
dérivés à l'effigie de l'acteur des dons
aussi provenant de fans vous avez des
tas d'objets qui viennent de tous les
pays qui non seulement sont liés à mes
recherches bien sûr parce que je me suis
intéressé directement au personnage
forcément il était sur site et quand on
commence à s'intéresser forcément on
creuse on creuse on creuse et puis on
retrouve des tâches sur le personnage
donc on vit au quotidien je dirais avec
le bonheur alors parfois c'est ennuie un
peu mes enfants qui disent papa arrête
avec ton histoire de bonnet etc tu nous
ennuis quelque peu il faut dire qu'ils
sont pas vraiment de la même génération
mais mais voilà ils se sont adaptés à la
chose et finalement ça fait partie c'est
un membre supplémentaire de la famille
hors saison le site privé est ouvert sur
réservation 600 à 700 visiteurs s'y
rendent chaque année soit pour découvrir
la tombe de l'acteur du roi et moi soit
pour mieux cerner l'histoire de cet
abbaye royale qui abrita une communauté
orthodoxe